on the outskirts of Moscow Russia is
building a mothership for its sovereign
tech they're coaxing companies and
workers here with promises of government
support blurring the boundaries between
Kremlin control and bootstraps
entrepreneurs
[Music]
Russia exploits that fuzziness as it
projects power on the web alongside
tenacious hackers the specialty of one
of spoke of as rising stars a
criminologist named Ilyas Sancho hello
are you I'm good
nice to see you yeah Ilya heads group I
be a private company based in Moscow
that tries to find ever-elusive Russian
hackers unmask them and then hand them
over to the authorities
we stomach like the superheroes in our
field we help our clients to solve very
very difficult cases we use their
branding like Phoebe I look at your
picture and you look like James Bond
this is Photoshop
Group IB specializes in investigating
fraud and theft the type of stuff that
makes up 99% of cybercrime people look
on the cybercrime like an iceberg they
could see only the upper things but
underwater a lot of infrastructure a lot
of politicians a lot of corrupt people
from the different organization and this
is the future they walk a tightrope
cooperating with Russian law enforcement
while also serving major international
clients like Citibank
and Microsoft you have foreign clients
today huge companies but as the tensions
between China in the US and Russia they
just seem to be escalating especially
when it comes to cybersecurity actually
we had office in New York it was really
funny experience because every week we
have had extortion from Phoebe I from
the New York police they ask what are
you doing here it just seems like that
will make it so much harder for you guys
to expand business I think without
knowledge that we really have good on
this think of Russia cybercrime so I
think this is competitive
but do you think with the tensions
between the US and Russia right now that
Russia would be upset if you had an
office in Silicon Valley I think yes we
have some toxic knowledge about
organized crime and cyber crime and I
think it's not government it's some
people in government private company
without any control do investigations
get some knowledge of cause they are not
happy
[Music]
my co-panelists my yellows fancy mere
diversion Spanish the rest of the group
responsive theme
you think of hackers is this guy sitting
in their basement with their hats and
their hoodies on this is what the people
look like who hunt them this is Russia's
largest cybercrime event
[Music]
choice
[Music]
[Music]
Julia started group I'd be in college
with a few buddies one of them is
Dimitri Volkov the company's head hacker
hunter
the gpna would appreciate necessarily
the toaster netiquette responsibilities
and a problematic utility is this was a
new military espionage they would sell
you at Christian sucia act aggressive
this servo mushnick of aDNA at noon
senior Maxima in the more wanna shields
likeness relationship to me people
senior Maxime monument from its own
weight is an answer I visited group i
beez Moscow office to find out more
about how to meet reach aces
cybercriminals
is the Russian hacking community is that
the the biggest cyber crime community in
the world very different so
russian-speaking hack is so famous
because we share knowledge with
development tools with information about
how to attack banks how security
measures applied on different systems so
huge amount of information is available
on the ground community
what's the art of that and the technique
main goal is to get the full history of
hackers activity because when hacker
starts can do a lot of mistakes
we have more than 100,000 profiles about
hackers who communicated on russian
speaking of the girl community this
fully automated rehab artificial
intelligence implementing on security
solutions we have special algorithms to
detect unknown programs and it's always
interesting to see interest attack a cow
carcass rank it up with techniques and
tools to do attacks
what does a Russian hacker look like who
are these people
if he's an attacker who is doing just
technical job usually he lives alone but
if we talk about organizers of foreign
schemes usually with these people are
very rich where they don't where who
it's way driving good cars living in
both houses have very beautiful woman
you can see it's like a mafia group I be
now occupies an uncomfortable position
at the intersection of Cold War
geopolitics and organized crime like the
Mafia from Russia's unruly Caucasus
during an early group IB investigation
Ilya learned that one of their targets
had ordered the mobsters to kill it you
can all about the kavkaza an organized
group it's not funny at all until you
have bodyguards
I had bodyguards for two years but I
didn't I I understand if someone would
like to do something bad they will do
[Applause]
after Matt kalashnikova apartment
premier journal posted out press
releases strandos avoid panels technical
social catastrophe familia de carreras
control erosion erosion topography image
store keeper terrorist market is
plausible computer uses double segundo
cheats territory traversed running to
provide notice is no catastrophic
catastrophic at aura is me at NASA plan
y todos no parasite astronomy viral easy
presumably Union stir me on by whisking
tournament press to play yet towards
towards to most festive
[Music]
you